this video is brought to you by nordvpn
give yourself options online go to
nordvpn.com forward slash biographics or
use code biographics for a huge discount
on a two-year plan
plus an additional bonus month for free
more on them in just a bit
every so often an author comes along
whose work defines a generation guys
like f scott fitzgerald in the 1920s or
ken casey and the
psychedelic 60s but perhaps none has
done such a profound job of shaping
young people's lives
as jack kerouac as leading light of the
beats kerouac champion to breathless
prose that was
lyrical in its intensity his most famous
book on the road used a rhythm of jazz
to
capture the experience of travel of sex
of wild parties and dive bars
perhaps more than any other book it
opened the eyes of millions to a new way
of being
of life outside the american mainstream
yet there was far more to kerouac than
just
youthful rebellion already in his
thirties when on the road came out
kerouac would spend the rest of his life
bitter about the way that his work was
classified rather than
a simple traveler he saw himself as a
modern catholic mystic
his writing not just autobiography but
a way of reaching some deep spiritual
truth misunderstood in both life and
death this is the story of jack kerouac
the writer who inspired a generation
for the author of a book as holy
american is on the road kerouac spent a
large part of his childhood to finally
outside of the american mainstream born
into an immigrant community of quebecois
in
lao massachusetts on march 12 1922 jack
didn't learn to speak
english until he started school in fact
his birth name wasn't even
jack his french-speaking parents leo and
gabrielle christened him
jean-louis de bruy de kerouac nor was it
only language that made the keralax
outsiders their home was the 1920s
quebecois ideal
tight-knit devoutly catholic and steeped
in ideas of suffering and penance
this faith would be a constant theme in
kerouac's recollections of his child
including both memories of church and
the red afternoon in dead frozen winter
when he realized he had a soul but the
sharpest memory
would also be the most traumatic all his
short life kerouac's older brother
gerard was ill and
venerated by their mother as a saint
when the boy died when karak was just
four they said that he slipped away
after having a vision of the virgin mary
the pain of gerrard's passing and
the religious experience that
accompanied her would have a profound
impact on jack's writing
the rest of carrock's childhood was
spent mostly on his two great loves
reading and sports embarrassed by his
accented english kerouac rarely spoke at
school until he was a teen preferring
instead to immerse himself in stories
when he was a child he decided he wanted
to write the great american novel
but really any literary pretensions were
just background noise to
sports from the moment he first stepped
onto a football field age 13.
kerouac was in love with the game he was
good at it too so good that he looked
like he might be able to get a
scholarship
in those desperate times this thought
was a lifesaver
once a semi-successful print shop owner
leo kerouac had been
wiped out by the great depression and
turned to alcohol although gabrielle
took work in a factory to make ends meet
the family was
dirt poor if he wanted to support his
folks kerouac needed to get an education
so it was in 1939 that the boy headed to
nyc on a football scholarship but
someone who'd grown up in lao
new york was like suddenly discovering
the joys of hort cuisine
after a life of only eating white bread
nyc in 1939 was the biggest city on the
planet the possibilities for experiences
for meeting people for just
living were endless but the thing that
would have the biggest impact on young
jack
would be jazz introduced to the smoky
nightclubs of harlem kerouac finally
found the music
that stirred his soul when it came time
to write his novels it would be the
improvisational style the rhythms of
jazz that
he aimed to capture in his words but
first he'd have to ditch the sports
in 1940 kerouac into colombia on his
football scholarship only to break his
leg in one of his first games
when his coach benched him for an entire
season he flew into a rage impulsively
dropped out and
declared that he was going to become a
writer as any aspiring novelist will
tell you
that's much much easier to say
than to do
in 1944 kerouac was still drifting
around the edges of student life at
columbia still trying to make his name
the previous four years had seen him do
everything from joining the construction
crew building the pentagon to
sailing with the merchant marines to
signing up to fight in world war ii and
getting discharged after only 10 days
he'd also written his first novel the
sea is my brother a book so bad kerouac
himself dismissed it as a croc
but hey at least he'd made some
interesting friends come 1944 kerouac
was
piling around with future household
names allen ginsberg and william s
burrows lounging around hit bars getting
drunk and
talking about poetry it was an
interesting life one that brought him
into contact with both
junky hustlers like herbert hung who
coined the term beat generation and rich
respectable girls like eddie parker who
jack started dating
it was also a life that led character to
question a lot of things not least to
sexuality
as literary movements go the beats were
a surprisingly queer one with both
ginsburg and burroughs being openly gay
the same can't be said of kerouac who
would marry three women in his lifetime
but
he had bisexual urges urges that would
one day lead him to seducing gore vidal
in summer of 1944 though the subject of
those urges
was lucian carr young and pretty car
caught the eye of plenty of men around
nyc
but he was also unstable an instability
that
boiled over when he stabbed a mutual
friend of kerouac and burrows to death
in the wake of the attack carr came to
kerouac for help together they disposed
of the bloody knife down a storm drain
unfortunately carbon confessed the
killing and jack was arrested as an
accessory to murder
unable to make bail his parents refusing
to help jack turned to eddie parker her
parents agreed to pay
on the condition that the pair get
married on august 22
1944 karoak was marched from the bronx
prison to the municipal building
where he and eddie tied the knot he was
then marched straight back under armed
guard
luckily he wouldn't be in prison much
longer car's defense and to this day no
one knows if it was true or an alibi was
that he killed his victim after the man
sexually assaulted him inclined to
believe that a dead homosexual man was a
good homosexual
the police didn't do much digging car
went down for just 18 months and kerak
was freed
short as kerak's time in jail was it did
have two significant effects the first
was that he and burroughs collaborated
on a book about their experience and the
hippos were boiled in their tanks
unreleased in their lifetimes it
nonetheless stands as kerouac's first
serious attempt at tackling a novel
the second is that it led to jack's
marriage to eddie and that's important
because it would be the high speed
breakdown of this marriage that pushed
kerouac to do something that had never
done before
to go on the road riots 1947 should have
been an abysmal year for jack kerouac
his father had died a few months back
his marriage was coming apart and his
new novel the town and the city
was taking ages to write but it's often
at our lowest
that we find inspiration the drive to do
something new and exciting
for kerouac that inspiration came in the
form of one man
neil cassidy born on february 8 1926
cassidy was the sort of character
you could never hope to write orphaned
at a young age he'd become a notorious
petty criminal in denver stealing
hundreds of cars and being sent in and
out of reform school but he was also
a formidable auto died act a guy who'd
read all the philosophy texts in the
public library consumed great literature
and now
talked in an amazing mix of high-flow
phrases and back annie slang
everyone who met him was fascinated by
him from allen ginsburg who'd
started a sexual relationship with
cassidy to kane casey in 1947 it was
kerouac's turn
to have his mind blown their first
meeting was typical cassidy after
hearing about this wild new guy in town
jack went to call on him
in east harlem only for cassidy to open
the door stark naked just a few months
later kerouac followed him back to
denver abandoning his crumbling marriage
to
hitchhike across america determined to
get to know the strange new man in his
life
it was the start of the frantic travels
that would form the backbone
of on the road it was also the start of
by far the most significant friendship
in kerak's life
in the months and years that he spent on
and off traveling with cassidy kerouac
came to see him as anything from a
long-lost brother to an idealized
version of himself
to a potential lover in short cassidy
became his muse the two of them
traveling together to california to
mexico to all sorts of places that jack
would later immortalize in prose but
doggo thinking it was a big
hedonistic adventure on the road's
reputation is a book about young
carefree spirits breaking out of stuffy
conformist society to find freedom
through travel
just look at the instagram ready 2012
movie
in reality a whole lot of those three
years it was based on were spent in
poverty and misery
a beat lifestyle was meant to mean both
being beat down and poor but also
beautiful in a catholic sense able to
find god through suffering it was this
later concept that kerouac developed
most fully he even called his most
famous novel really the story of two
catholic buddies roaming the country in
search of god key to that search was
suffering and
boy was there ever a lot of it karak
would later recount being dirt poor on
the west coast having to scrounge
cigarettes off the ground and
not even being able to afford a bread
roll others had even darker memories
cassidy's first wife luanne henderson
was just 16 when she found herself
having to nurse the grown kerouac
through an all-night crying jag in some
desolate hotel speaking of henderson
much of kerouac and cassidy's travels
were only made possible by them
effectively abandoning their wives and
in cassidy's case
kids for long stretches so forget your
misconceptions about on the road being a
chronicle of youthful freedom
in reality it documented three years of
fairly miserable semi-religious
wandering interspersed with a few lively
parties and a lot of sexual
experimentation
difficult as those years may have been
though they did furnish kerouac with the
inspiration that he needed
as early as october 1947 it decided he
wanted to write a story about two men
hitchhiking east
just as he and cassidy had done it would
take several more years and a whole lot
more suffering before that idea became
the novel
that would make his name now if you
don't want to wait several years for a
secure internet experience it's time to
check out today's video sponsor nordvpn
look guys it's not the 1990s it's time
to bring your internet experience
up to the present day vpns aren't just a
more modern way to use the internet
they're just straight up better
and with nordvpn i can rest easy knowing
that my internet uses safe behind the
wall of next generation encryption
block malware and bypass annoying ad
that are tracking your web traffic it's
just a more secure experience online
you're worried about data logs well
don't be nordvpn doesn't keep logs on
your internet use because
they know where you go is none of their
business
what they do give you is more than 5000
server options scattered across 59
countries so your ip can live
wherever you want it to and that can
provide access to loads of new options
from shopping
to streaming just one click and you're
good to go so regardless of whether
you're considering a vpn for yourself or
as a gift for another internet user in
your life
nord gives you options right now you
guys can take advantage of a special
deal that nordvpn is running any
purchase of a two-year plan
comes with a huge discount plus an
additional month for free and
if you make a purchase and decide a vpn
isn't for you nordvpn offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee but there's never
been a better time to enhance your
online experience with nordvpn
said to nordvpn.com forward slash
biographics or just use the code
biographics at checkout
or just follow the link in the
description box below and let's get back
to jack
[Music]
a big part of the mythology of on the
road is that kerouac wrote it in three
weeks flat while that's technically true
it ignores the years of hard work that
went into getting to that moment when
kerouac first started what was then gone
on the road
he still thought of himself as a
literary writer that meant carefully
crafted sentences characters who were
symbols
intricate plotting it also meant a hell
of a boring book
the boys hitchhiking east were the
grandchildren of characters in a great
family saga they were half brothers
trying to woo
the same girl in other words kerouac had
no idea what they were
or what his novel really was while his
notebook and diary were starting to show
the rapid lyrical pros he'd soon be
famous for his great american novel was
aladdin tome more likely to kill
teenagers with boredom than inspire them
that it ever evolved into something
readable is thanks entirely to cassidy
since they met back in 1947 kerouac had
been convinced that cassidy was a great
writer
who needed to find his voice he
encouraged him to write letters sketches
whatever came to his mind in december
1950 cassidy finally produced the
masterpiece that kerouac had dreamed of
the joan anderson letter was a 40-page
confessional that recorded every single
one of cassidy's affairs
in unvarnished detail it had clearly
been written in a rush without much
thought for the niceties of literature
and it transformed kerouac's life
compelled to write an instant
unvarnished reply of his own kerouac
dashed off his confessional letter
sending it back to cassidy as soon as it
was finished
it was in that mad rush of his reply
that jack finally cracked it how he
wanted to write
how it always wanted to write the rest
of the pieces quickly fell into place
helping clean out the apartment of a
recently deceased friend kerouac
stumbled across a stack of architecture
paper
taking it home he taped the whole lot
together creating
one giant scroll by spring 1951
jack was writing like mad in his
notebooks jotting memories of his
travels
all with the free-flowing energy that
had found writing to cassidy he was even
creating a new rhythm to accompany it
one which flowed like jazz with
normal punctuation replaced by dashes
signifying when to breathe
ginsburg would later call this
spontaneous bot prosidy kerouac would
claim with tonya hinderbyrony that it
was the work of the holy ghost
the last piece of the puzzle landed in
march 1951
that day beat writer john clelland
holmes showed kerouac his manuscript for
go an autobiographical retelling of
their lives
outraged that some young punk had beaten
him to it kerouac decided he had to
write his novel now
or risk being and also ran on the
evening of april the 2nd 1951 he fed his
scroll of architecture paper into his
typewriter and poured a bathtub size mug
of coffee what he typed next
is the stuff of legend karak wrote for
20 days straight hitting 6 000 words a
day at first before picking up speed
words tumbled from recollections images
moments spent traveling america with
neil cassidy brought to life again on
the page
the more karak wrote the more his style
matured giving way
from terse hemingway sentences to mad
flowing paragraphs
by the end the scroll itself resembled a
road 120 feet long
and winding across the floor it was a
feat of endurance equal to anything jack
had ever achieved on the football field
the creation of not just an
autobiographical story
but an american myth now we just had to
find someone who'd
buy the damn thing
[Music]
on april 22nd 1951 robert juro got a
strange
call it was jack kerouac whose novel the
town of the city jerod edited
the writer was raving that he had a
masterpiece one that he needed to show
him shortly after kerouac swaggered unto
jesus office and unveiled the scroll
across the floor
here it is he shouted written by the
holy ghost
by now the scroll was battered beyond
belief knocked about when
kerouac broke up with his second wife
and moved in with lucian carr
then chewed up around the edges by
carr's dog but kerouac didn't care he
was ecstatic certain had made a literary
breakthrough he was even talking about
having it published in scroll format
in shock jarrow told him making this
mess readable was going to take a ton
of editing carrick's response well he
told gero
you have offended the holy ghost and
stormed out of his office and never
worked with him again if that sounds
like a slight overreaction remember to
put this in the context of kerouac's
religion when kerouac's head on the road
was written by the holy ghost he was
being at least
half serious with his new style he'd
come to believe revision was a form of
lying or stripping away the brief
ecstatic glimpse of
spiritual truth that writing could
afford if the trance-like state of
writing was communion with the catholic
god then editing wasn't just an attack
on his ego
it was practically a sin it's this
attitude that probably explains why on
the road took so long to appear in print
all through the first half of the 50s
kerouac's friends were sending the
scroll to publishers
trying to stir interest they even got
kerouac to gradually retype it on
regular paper
to make it easier for editors to read
but as 1951 gave way to 1952
a strange thing happened kerouac gave up
on his novel by the new year kerouac was
writing other books based on the same
trips using
an even purer style of composition the
subterraneans was written on a
three-day amphetamine bender while
visions of cody had sections more like
poetry the more kerouac matured the
greater religious ecstasy he came to
receive from writing until he regarded
on the road
as a mere transition something that
paved the way for his newer work
he was also traveling again expanding
his horizons getting drawn into buddhism
a religion ginsburg thought jack
responded to because of its emphasis on
the catholic-like suffering of existence
that is
so deep that it is joyful in fact
kerouac had pretty much forgotten the
scroll when he got a call in 1955 and
discovered the viking was willing to
take a chance on publishing it
but they were going to need major
changes what followed was a torturous
two-year back and forth as kerak tried
to cling on to his original vision
while viking tried to get a book that
they could actually sell
at long last desperately broken in need
of cash kerouac agreed
to let the editors make changes they
didn't give him a chance to approve
their edits just chopped out
all the realistic descriptions of sex
changed the names broke up the long
sentences that contained the book's
music
that september a butchered version of on
the road hit the bookshelves but it
still had enough of kerouac
to cause a sensation just after midnight
on september 5th 1957
kerouac stood with his girlfriend joyce
johnson and read gilbert milstein's
review in the new york times
just as more than any other novel of the
20s the sun also rises came to be
regarded as the testament of the lost
generation
so it seems certain that on the road
will come to be known as that
of the beat generation in shock carrack
asked johnson if that was a good review
or not
she assured him that it was as johnson
later put it
when they both went to bed that night
kerouac was obscure
by the time he woke up the next morning
he'd be famous
okay so we've just seen kerouac
publisher's best seller aged 35.
there must still be a hell of a long way
to go
in this video right well sadly no
this is it this is the final chapter the
last part to tell
that's because within a year of on the
roads publication karak would suffer a
life-changing injury
within four years he'd have published
the last of his best-known books
by the time the late 1960s rolled around
it'd be broke addicted to alcohol
and on the verge of a painful death it's
a buckle up because it's all downhill
from here
the moment on the road landed kerouac
became a literary superstar a household
name for millions inspired by his work
but also a target for relentless mockery
truman capote for example famously
dismissed carax prose as
typing not writing but the worst part of
being famous
was being recognized in april 1958 a
gang of drunks noticed kerouac drinking
a crappy bar
they attacked him beat him unconscious
smacking his head repeatedly against the
sidewalk although kerouac was cleared
for concussion he later came to suspect
that it suffered brain damage
certainly his life post knight 58 is
characterized by behavior linked
head injury depression memory loss poor
impulse control substance abuse
and it would explain a whole lot of what
came next by the early 1960s kerala
was increasingly turning to drink to
cope with the pressures of fame to
cope with his recurrent depression he
still found time to write putting out
his
last great novel big sur in 1961 but
already
his work was sliding towards irrelevance
in 1962 neil cassidy showed up at the
door of ken
casey author of one flew over the curcus
nest beginning
his time with the mary pranksters
interested in lsd psychedelics and
freeing their minds the pranksters would
soon help kickstart a whole new youth
movement one that would quickly make the
beatniks look as relevant as
yuppies do today the hippies not that
hippie culture had no time for the beats
though
both ginsburg and cassidy became fully
paid-up members of the movement and a
whole bunch of hippies were inspired by
on the road but kerouac sure as hell had
no
time for them as someone who'd served
his country in the merchant marines
kerouac was disgusted by what he saw as
the counter-culture's anti-americanism
the more guys like casey trampled on the
flag the more kerouac moved away from
their movement
and that would have been fine if only he
had something to move on too
as it was he only had drink come the
late 1960s kerouac's alcohol problem had
gone beyond merely problematic and
become something that was eating him
alive although he'd married his third
wife stella he'd
also become prone to mood swings and
outbursts of violence
he'd broken off contact with ginsburg
and burrows over perceived slights
it turned into a recluse living in
poverty with only his mum and stella for
company
he became obsessed with conspiracy
theories that neil cassidy hadn't really
died in 1968 that communists and jews
were
controlling america's youth you can see
the allure of the brain damage theory
1969 kerouac was so different from 1958
kerouac
that it just demands an explanation but
maybe there's no need to look beyond the
simplest explanation of all like his
father before him kerouac had slipped
deep into alcoholism there was nothing
left in his life but getting drunk and
ranting about the world when your only
coping mechanism is to take a drink it's
inevitable that
eventually the drink will take you
alcohol finally killed jack kerouac on
the 21st of october 1969.
aged just 47 kerouac died bitter and
alone
his books nearly all out of print half
forgotten by the culture that had
embraced him just a decade before
it was a miserable end a fate no one
deserves but of course
it wasn't really the end today kerouac
is part of the american canon
millions still read his work not just on
the road but also dharma bums
desolation angels and more and millions
are inspired by it
to change their lives it's a fitting
legacy for kerouac to end up an icon but
it's also a legacy that misses out on an
important part of kerouac's story
here was a man who wasn't just a rebel
but an experimental writer who tried to
put on paper
what was happening at a specific point
in u.s history the experience of blue
collar catholic youth at
a time of great social change in
embracing both the real
and spiritual he created books that
refused to be classified that saw
at once travelogues novels religious
texts and
autobiography but never anything less
than fascinating the man behind them may
have died forgotten
and unloved but his work will continue
to resonate
for decades to come so i really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do
hit that thumbs up button below don't
forget to subscribe and thank you for
watching
[Music]